الان المغرب مع سوريا
هذه الاجواء الاحتفالاتنا
[تصفيق]
الف مبروك
هذه بهذا الفوز فوز المنتخب المغربي هنا
في الدوحه على كندا اثنين الى واحد هذا ما
قد سمعا ايه
والله شرف لنا يعني شرف كبير لانك
اي الشعب المغربي وجميع الشعوب العربيه
لسانده المغرب صراحه
[تصفيق]
الواد الازرق
حتى ساعات الصباح الباكر بعد هذا المكان
[تصفيق]
المنتخب المصري
[موسيقى]
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه ولا عود اليك
ميسون ان الرضع كبيره ليث ليث اعذرني ولكن
لم نسمعك قلت اتحدث عن مسيره ام ماذا لما
لم نفهم بالضبط ماذا سيحصل الان
حاولت ابتعد عن الحسود شوي بس من شان اقدر
اسمع بسرعه ليث
طب داني داني اذهب الى عادل لان الصوره
غير واضحه ومسمى اعود اليك عدل الزبير من
الرباط مبروك عقل هذا هذا الربح اليوم
الاجواء لديك
[موسيقى]
مرحبا مرحبا ميسون
انطلقت الافراح المغربيه بعد مباراه لم
تكن سهله المباراه الثالثه لمنتخب المغرب
ينجح في اعاده انجاز مكسيكو 86
والان ليله طويله من الافراح المغربيه في
كل الشوارع في كل المدن في كل القرى
المغربيه التاهل لم يكن سهلا
ان يقرب الصوره اكثر لمتابع الجماهير التي
طبعا
يعمها الفرح هذه الشوارع طعمها الافراح
اليوم بربح المنتخب
المغربي الذي نعود ونذكر انها المره
الاولى في التاريخ ان يتصدر منتخب عربي
مجموعته وهذا ما حصل مع المنتخب المغربي
بعد فوزه على كندا اليك عادل مجددا
انا احاول اقتراب من الجماهير كما نشاهد
هنا في هذه الساحه وكما كل الساحات
المغربيه رفع الاعلام المغربيه
وكذلك ارتداء للاقمصه وهذه الطفله الصغيره
ايضا الافراح المغربيه بدات ولن تنتهي
بسهوله المغرب للمره الثانيه يتاهل الى
نهائيات كاس العالم
وهناك ايضا ظهور
للنساء اللواتي اصبحنا ايضا يشجعات
للمنتخب المغربي هذه هي الاجواء هنا في
العاصمه الرباط الجمهور المغربي سعيد جدا
بهذا الانتصار لانه جاء بعد صبر طويل منذ
نفسه 86 المغاربه الان يرفعون راسه وفقرا
بين اثارها والعرب انهم ممثل الوحيد
الباقي لمنتخب للمنتخبات العربيه نعم هذه
الاجواء
الاهلي
يعني على كل حال عدل من الصوره والصوت
يتكلمان هذه الفرحه بنجاح وربح المنتخب
المغربي الذي تاهل الى دور 16 لا ادري اذا
كان لدي بعض من الوقت لنذهب ايضا الى ليث
وتابعه ماذا يجري في الدوحه من اجواء لا
يسعود اليك
الاجواء
حاولنا نبعد عنها شوي بس حتى نقدر نحكي
والوصل الفكره
بتقول لك هاي البدايه يعني هذا اللي راح
الاول وان شاء الله يستمر ويا محاسن الصدف
يا ميسون انه احنا امام ملعب
نفس الوقت في كاس العالم موجود هون
كثير من المشجعين المغاربه يحتفلون
ويرفعون الرايه الحمراء والخضراء والنجمه
المغربيه هنا في هذا المكان ويقولون الكاس
الحقيقي سوف يكون المغرب ان شاء الله
مستحق بعد مباريات
برع فيها متالقه فيها المنتخب المغربيه
هذا الفوز مستحق هو فوز طبعا المغرب ولكن
ايضا لكل الدول العربيه حيث سيتاهل المغرب
لدور ال16 ونعود ونذكر مشاهدينا بانه هذه
المره الاولى منتخب عربيه تصدر مجموعته
وهذا ما حصل اليوم المغرب بعد الفوز على
كندا